So on this program, I try to strike the right
balance between being complacent and being
alarmist.
I try to avoid being either.
I try to just be realistic and kind of give
it to you straight.
Simply telling you that there is concern among
Democrats about Minnesota I think is accurate.
I don't think it's alarmist and I don't think
it's complacent.
Donald Trump, according to some Democratic
strategists, could win the state of Minnesota.
And you might be worried.
You might be wondering, Minnesota, are we
should we really be worried about that?
Why?
Well, the truth is that Minnesota hasn't voted
for a Republican presidential candidate since
1972.
That's just shy of 50 years ago.
And if you look at the polling, it sort of
looks okay.
Right.
I mean, it looks OK for Joe Biden.
Joe Biden is currently leading the polling
in Minnesota by an average of three point
seven.
But the problem is that three point seven
really isn't that much to be comfortable with.
Minnesota was actually already almost a problem
for Hillary Clinton in 2016.
Hillary Clinton did win Minnesota in 2016,
but only by about one point five.
And if you look further into history, Barack
Obama won Minnesota by eleven.
In 2008, he won it by eight.
In 2012, John Kerry won Minnesota by four.
In 2004, Al Gore won it only by two in the
year 2000.
And so when you see it this close and you
know that there's voter suppression, that's
not in the polling there, there's meddling.
That's not in the polling.
There's all sorts of things that are not reflected
by the polling.
I am not particularly comfortable with Joe
Biden being up by only three point seven in
the state of Minnesota.
Now, there's another reason that Minnesota
could be a problem.
And Minnesota could turn into the Wisconsin
of 2020.
Remember, in 2016, Hillary Clinton was widely
criticized for not spending time in Wisconsin,
a state that she ultimately lost by a very
small margin.
And it was one of those three states that
flipped the results to Donald Trump electorally.
Joe Biden may have a similar situation right
now.
And what I mean by that is in Florida, Joe
Biden is struggling with Latino voters right
now in Florida.
And it seems as though Joe Biden is going
to have to devote even more resources to Florida.
Florida always a focal point, particularly
for Democrats, because taking Florida away
from the Republican candidate is so powerful
in these electoral races to 270.
But again, if Joe Biden has to put more time
and effort into Florida than he would otherwise
have to ordinarily have to wear it, not for
the Hispanic vote.
He may not have the resources or time in Minnesota.
And Minnesota is exactly the type of state
that the polling could get wrong.
Remember, the 2016 polling was mostly correct
at the national level, at the national level.
The polling said Hillary's up three and she
won by more than two in the popular vote.
But it is also true that the polling was not
correct in Wisconsin.
In Wisconsin, Hillary Clinton in the polling
was winning by six and a half.
And you might recall, as I just mentioned
five minutes ago, Donald Trump won Wisconsin
by about three quarters of a point.
The Wisconsin polling was very, very wrong.
So what do we do about Minnesota, about all
of these situations?
Well, we learned from the past.
We learned from past experiences.
We understand that Democrats are worried about
Minnesota.
And so we should be worried about Minnesota
and we should focus on it when Trump advisers
what living backup when Trump publicly says
all our polls look great, we're winning everything.
It's B.S.
We all know it's B.S.
When privately Trump advisers and Republican
strategists say we're not writing off Michigan.
We understand that Michigan could get complicated
when privately they start looking again at
a state like Minnesota.
We understand that.
We can't ignore it.
We never stop the focus on getting out the
vote.
And any one of these states could be the difference
maker now in the coming weeks.
I'm going to show you some of my plausible
electoral maps.
Now, why the hell would you listen to me about
that?
You really shouldn't.
I got it way wrong in in 2016 and 2016.
I believed the Wisconsin polling and so on
my map.
I had Wisconsin definitely for Hillary.
I was wrong.
But I am going to give you some scenarios.
And incredibly, there is a scenario for for
this upcoming election that would put the
electoral votes at 269 to 269.
It's not the most likely scenario, but it's
also not that unlikely.
And it depends on Maine being split, as they
do in terms of their electoral votes.
So we will get to that.
We have plenty of time for that.